هل كنت راضيًا عما سمعته
من فلاديمير بوتين بالأمس جيدًا ،
أعتقد أنه كان اجتماعًا مفيدًا للغاية أولاً
وقبل كل شيء لأنه كان من الممكن إخبار
الرئيس بوتين بنفس الأشياء التي أقولها
في نيويورك أو سأتمكن من قولها هنا في
كييف
مما يعني أن أه الغزو الروسي
أه ضد
الأمم المتحدة الميثاق هو انتهاك
لوحدة أراضي أوكرانيا وهذا
يعني أن الحرب يجب أن تنتهي في أسرع وقت
ممكن وفي نفس الوقت
مخاوفنا من
انتهاكات
القانون الدولي للبحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​قانون حقوق الإنسان
احتمالية ارتكاب جرائم حرب حتى
أتمكن من التعبير عن هذه المخاوف
بوضوح شديد وبصراحة شديدة وفي نفس الوقت
أجريت مناقشة جادة للغاية حول كيف
يمكننا على الأقل تقليل بعض المواقف الأكثر
دراماتيكية وركزت
جهودي أه في
ممرات المساعدات الإنسانية والإجلاء  وبالأخص
حالة المدنيين
المحاصرين في أه
معمل الحديد في ماريون قد يصل
عددهم إلى ألف مدني.
في آخر
إحصاء للممرات الإنسانية ، كان الأمر
محبطًا للغاية بالنسبة
للأوكرانيين الذين يحاولون الخروج من روسيا ،
وتقول روسيا إن الأحياء مفتوحة ومع ذلك
يقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون
إنهم يواصلون قصف المواقع
أو قد تكون الأحياء مفتوحة ولكنهم يتجهون
فقط
إلى روسيا ،
هل تعتقد أن فلاديمير بوتين
سيسمح للمدنيين في ماريوبول بالقيادة
عندما يصلون إلى أوكرانيا ،
فلنكن واضحين أن الرئيس بوتين وافقني من
حيث المبدأ على
أننا سنحصل
عليه بدعم من الولايات المتحدة وبدعم
من اللجنة الدولية
للصليب الأحمر  من شأنها أن تؤدي إلى
إجلاء هؤلاء المدنيين
إلى الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها
الحكومة الأوكرانية ،
ونحن نعمل على التفاصيل
في الوقت الحالي ، حيث يتم
مناقشتها في موسكو
بين وزارة الدفاع
وشعبنا هنا أيضًا على اتصال مع
حكومة  أوكرانيا لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاننا أن
نواجه موقفًا لا يمكن لأحد أن
يلوم فيه الطرف الآخر على
الأشياء التي لا تحدث
لفترة قصيرة.  إذا كان هناك خطر نووي شهدته
أمام الكونجرس قبل فترة قصيرة
بأن احتمالية
نشوب صراع دولي كبير لا
يتناقص ، فأنا أقتبس منك منذ ذلك الحين
، أصدرت روسيا احتجاجًا دبلوماسيًا
إلى الولايات المتحدة وحلف شمال الأطلسي لوقف
شحنات الأسلحة لديها تلك الزيادة في الجيش
الدعم من وجهة نظرك
يزيد من خطر نشوب صراع مباشر
بين الولايات المتحدة وروسيا ،
نعم أعتقد بالفعل أن العكس هو الصحيح ،
أعتقد أن
ما هو على المحك هنا أكبر
بكثير من أوكرانيا ، ما هو على المحك
هو أمن أوروبا ، هذا هو
التحدي الأكبر للأمن  من
أوروبا منذ نهاية الحرب العالمية الثانية ،
وبالفعل يمكنك بسهولة إثبات
أن ما هو على المحك هو نظام
الأمن الدولي العالمي
الذي تم وضعه في عام 1945.
واستمرت تلك الأوامر الدولية 78
عامًا ، فقد منعت حرب القوى
العظمى وتأكيد ذلك  مفهوم أه
كله فكرة أن أمم كبيرة أه
لن تقوم بعدوان عسكري على
دول صغيرة
وذاك  ر هو بالضبط ما حدث هنا
عدوان عسكري روسي غير مبرر
على دولة صغيرة لذا إذا
ترك هذا للوقوف أه إذا لم يكن هناك
رد على هذا العدوان أه إذا أفلتت روسيا
من هذه التكلفة مجانًا
أه إذن هكذا يذهب ما يسمى
الدولي  النظام وإذا حدث
ذلك فنحن ننتهي في حقبة من
عدم الاستقرار المتزايد بشكل خطير لذا
فقد حان
الوقت الآن والآن هناك فرصة
لوقف العدوان أه ولإعادة السلام
والأمن إلى القارة الأوروبية
لا أستطيع  لنفترض أننا كنا نتوقع ولكن
كان من السهل جدًا توقع أن روسيا
قد
تستخدم
موارد الطاقة
كسلاح لابتزازنا ، ولهذا السبب لتأمين
أمن الطاقة
لدينا ، فقد اتخذنا هذه القرارات الآن
نحن في وضع أفضل بكثير وعلى الرغم من
أنني أستطيع أن أتخيل  أنه لا يمكن ابتزاز بولندا فقط
بمثل هذه الخطوة ، بل إنها
علامة تجاه ألمانيا أو البلدان الأخرى
التي يجب عليهم حقًا التنويع فيها وأيضًا
جذور طاقتهم ، فلا ينبغي أن يكون
ذلك  يعتمدون كثيرًا على الغاز الروسي
الآن ، أنا متأكد من أن لديهم نية
للقيام بذلك في أسرع وقت ممكن ولكن
هذا لا يحدث بين عشية وضحاها ، هل أنت
قلق حيث قال بعض المراقبين والمحللين
أن هذه خطوة من قبل روسيا
لتقسيم أوروبا بشكل أساسي بين
البلدان التي لديها القدرة على
تحمل قطع صادرات الغاز الطبيعي
من روسيا وأولئك الذين ليس لديهم
بالضرورة هذه القدرة لأن
ليس لديهم بدائل مثل ألمانيا ، ما مدى
قلقك من أن هذه ستكون
النتيجة النهائية لهذه الخطوة ،
بالتأكيد
روسيا  يحب هذا المبدأ
يقسم حتمية يقسمنا ثم
يحصل على أه يحصل أهدافه السياسية
ولهذا نحتاج إلى الوحدة التي نحتاجها
للتعبير عن تضامننا الذي كان أه
هذا ما كنا نحذر
شركائنا وحلفائنا من أن روسيا قد تستخدم
هذه
الطاقة كسلاح  أعني إمدادات الغاز موارد الطاقة